Maybe the most infamous statement ever
made by, certainly an FCC regulator
was 1981 by Marc Fowler who said in a recent magazine interview
that in other markets we want to have a lot of competition, we let consumers vote,
we really should look at this like it's a toaster with pictures,
let the market figure this out.
The toaster tsunami as I talked about it
has just unleashed not just in content
because we've we've liberalized cable
and the web and everything so much.
But now we say here's some radio spectrum
the ecosystem is yours to create imagine and play with
Hi I'm Nick Gillespie for Reason,
today we're talking with Thomas Winslow Hazlett
an economics professor at
Clemson, a longtime Reason contributor
former chief economist of the Federal
Communications Commission
and author most recently of the epic new book:
'The Political Spectrum:
the Tumultuous Liberation of Wireless Technology from
Herbert Hoover to the Smartphone'
Tom, thanks for talking to us.
Thanks for having me, Nick.
The book is a masterful counterblast, I think,
to the intellectual status quo when it comes to broadcast and cable internet
especially related to things like spectrum auctions
and net neutrality and whatnot.
Your large argument is that government inhibits innovation rather than encourages it,
is that accurate?
yeah that's the starting point but certainly go farther
a lot farther in this book because there
has been significant liberalisation and
we learn a lot from the directions we've
gone we see the suppression through
administrative allocations of spectrum
which just means that we have this
mother mae-eye system where the
government's in charge of hoodoos does
what and wireless and has to give
explicit permission we've gone from a
system like that to a modern system that
has a lot of places where stuff can
happen without permission but and and we
have seen that the you know what we call
perhaps the smartphone revolution and
some other great stuff in the wireless
space has really urgent I mean we have
these emerging networks and ecosystems
that comes from deal of deregulation is
that deregulation or is it government I
mean and I guess in different examples
and what we'll talk about those but
sometimes it's explicitly regulate
or the government saying we're going to
get out of this we're not going to do
anything other times is it benign
neglect or innovators and entrepreneurs
doing what some people call
permissionless innovation where they
don't really care too much and they just
go ahead and do something then figure
out how to how to explain it later on
well great question and I think one of
the problems we had in spectrum is that
you can't really have benign neglect
there's their rules and if you have an
innovation that needs access to radio
spectrum because it's a wireless device
you have to go and ask for some kind of
authorization and so we've had to make a
lot of explicit rules and some of them
have been in the right direction and
that's very important to state it's not
- yeah yeah the government did did this
wrong and boy it's even worse over here
they did this wrong it's not just bad
worse worst we have gone in some
directions much better there's a lot
farther to go though and there's a lot
of stuff out there that's being
suppressed we don't we don't know what
most of that is but there's a lot of
innovation that could come if we lower
those barriers still more tell us the
story about Herbert Hoover and the
creation of the federal radio Commission
in 1927 and and how that kind of
undergirds I mean it's obviously it's
the starting point of your book but it's
also the concept that spectrum is
politicized in ways that are problematic
here's a great historical story for you
we got broadcasting in 1920 officially
when KDK and Pittsburg started this new
business of just putting up a tall
transmitter and blasting everywhere
around some programming coming to us out
of the sky
the longer voice of radio brings endless
hours of entertainment information and
Cheer and it could be received it was a
one-way communication and radio
receivers would pick up programming for
news and entertainment it caught on like
wildfire within two years or 500
broadcasting stations in the United
States and the issue of scarcity in the
airwaves congestion conflict actually
comes up this is really the first time
that happens and and so that's that in
those 500 stations some of them are
broadcasting on the same frequency or
overlapping or getting in the way well
they could and what
but what happens there was a
coordination mechanism under essentially
common law rules for property there were
first-come first-serve enforcement of
rules by the Department of Commerce it
had the authority to issue it couldn't
deny but it could issue rights and then
limit newcomers there are only a limited
number of frequencies or pathways
through the air to carry all these
programs to keep them from interfering
with each other the government groups
all radio stations into a certain
classification so under the system a
first-come first-serve we do have a
Department of Commerce be the first
regulator Herbert Hoover was Secretary
of Commerce 1921 to 1928 he was very
smart he was an engineer he met with the
radio industry knew a lot about the
technology and he was very savvy in
terms of the politics of it the radio
industry goes crazy by 1924 it's radio
Christmas Madison Avenue has gotten
ahold of this millions of people are
buying radio sets the whole panorama of
life and the world today presented for
the enlightenment and pleasure of
everyone this is all without any new
regulation for broadcasting but Hoover
wanted more he said as an administrative
matter we know how to get you know rules
in place where the market can develop
what we really want is the government to
have a larger say in who broadcast and
what the content is so where does that
come from though because the print press
it was unlicensed newspapers were
unlicensed why is there this belief that
the government even has the brighter the
ability to start - that was the question
Hoover for years tried to get a bill
passed that created a sort of commission
style regulation at the Department of
Commerce under his Aegis he couldn't get
it passed he said people keep saying if
the markets working why do we have to
legislate that was one problem another
thing is that there was disagreement on
exactly what to do and people were
distrustful of Hoover a lot of
Republicans even said he's going to just
use this to run for president by the way
the Senate didn't want regulation to be
at the Department of Commerce they want
it to be an independent condition where
the nominees by the president confirmed
by the Senate through the senate power
in the
of 1926 Hoover explicitly takes the site
of I don't have enough authority to
continue policing the airwaves okay so
he takes the position that all hands are
off there is no first come first serve
role anymore and everything is open and
that does create some chaos and now
demand for regulation goes up and so
there finally is a compromise
legislation passes and Coolidge signs
the bill February 23rd 1927 we still
have the same law today 90 years later
here we are operating under these Public
Interest standard know first-come
first-serve in fact there's an explicit
section of the law that says no licensee
using airwaves can claim a vested
interest in the property so we
eliminated this sort of property
approach and and we went in a different
direction where in fact it is mother
mae-eye we have to get explicit
permission to use the airwaves and this
is still in place I mean obviously
people are probably familiar where when
they hear about FCC potentially pulling
the license of the station that runs
nudity or profanity or something like
that or isn't representative enough of
certain types of minority classes etc
licenses come up for renewal and you
gotta you got to reapply and you got to
meet the standards it's a public
interest standard public interest
convenience or necessity yeah now think
about that for a while and ask yourself
what does that exclude what could the
government do
that's not definitionally public
interest convenience or necessity so
that gave us very vague standard to
policymakers Hoover like that Senator
dill Washington Democrat CC bill like
that and he sponsored the legislation
and was compromised but also the
incumbent radio stations loved it
because they had gotten established
stations Westinghouse RCA and so forth
major innovators in the field no doubt
but they also saw that under the
first-come first-serve rules new entry
could take place and challenge them they
actually cut that off very successfully
arguing for the law and then arguing
against any expansion under the federal
Radio Commission
which in 1934 became a Federal
Communications Commission the law just
getting folded into the Communications
Act of 34 and then as TV developed TV
was just kind of slotted into the same
thing and the TV licences went to you
know those licensees who proved they
were operating the Public Interest
before they got the license who you know
and one of the things that's great about
the book in your general approach is
that it as you were saying earlier it's
I mean it's not all it's not cowboys and
Indians all of these people are kind of
suspect I mean it's big business and big
government creating you know more and
more restrictions and the ability of
people to move into markets and innovate
fast forward a little bit to Lyndon
Johnson what happened under LBJ that was
particularly that undergird your idea
that spectrum is a politican din to a
political hot potato some people
particularly on the Left today still
write articles Pei ons to Lawrence fly
the FCC Chairman appointed by Franklin
Roosevelt some people argue he might be
the best SEC chairman in history the
cleanest most stand-up guy there was
well what happens is that there was a
powerful Georgia congressman congressman
Cox who ran into a little issue when he
was found actually be operating as an
attorney he was a lawyer and he actually
had a representation of a radio station
was up for a license renewal and charged
the radio station to help them on their
renewal and this went to the newspapers
and it was unseemly for a congressman to
are you taking money in this sort of
fashion milking the system he thought
nothing would happen just a bad a bad
day of the newspaper but the FCC
actually scheduled hearings on this and
that's that's the Commissioner or
Chairman flies credit well this
congressman went crazy and he said let's
just X out the whole FCC budget brutal
brutal attack on the FCC a young
congressman from Texas it was close to
the speaker Sam Rayburn saw an
opportunity and Johnson at the end of
the day helps save the FCC and Johnson
used that offer
to ingratiate himself with FCC
commissioners and staff and at the end
of the day had come away with an Austin
Texas radio license and an upgrade to
full time 24/7 operations when it was a
daytime only station he bought the
station cheap he actually bought it and
got this license modification when
another group had been there for years
trying to do this unsuccessfully he and
Lady Bird who nominally owned the
station got the license they ended up
for years being essentially the most
successful radio station then the most
successful television station licensee
in Austin when that came and of course
for years they were the only television
station licensed in Austin Texas Johnson
died one of the wealthiest former
presidents in the history of the United
States almost entirely because of his
media fortune earned through SEC
largesse and and I will say that while
he was President of the United States
he actually had broadcast company
executives sitting in the Oval Office
talking to him about affiliation
agreements in terms that might be more
favorable to the owner of a TV station
in Austin Texas so this is the process
that breeds this kind of outcome even
under the best of circumstances and
that's that's what that that gives us
well you know one alternative like you
know shows up in your book one of the
chapters discussing the rise of cable TV
is titled thank God for c-span a couple
quick questions you know what what's so
great about c-span in your estimation
and how did the FCC work to screw over
cable TV for so long and why did they do
that it seems odd so I answer the the
first yeah with a starting with the
answer the second so the most famous
speech ever given by any US regulator
may 1961 National Association of
Broadcasters annual convention Las Vegas
Nevada FCC chairman Newton Minow tells
the assembled executives from the
broadcast television industry
your product sucks we are the regulators
and we are going to hold your feet to
the fire okay I challenge you to watch
television I think that it's terrible
look like the vast wasteland sure is a
vast wasteland you will see a procession
of game shows formula comedies about
totally unbelievable families blood and
thunder mayhem violence sadism murder
Western Badman Western good men
privatized gangsters more violence in
cartoons
the vast wasteland cable as it says is
not over the air broadcasting and in
fact there's nothing in the 1934
Communications Act of the 1927 radio app
it says you have to regulate this or
even that you can and the FCC had
already decided it was outside the
jurisdiction and in fact it was benign
how how do I know how widespread is
cable at this point in time not
widespread and in fact that's part of
the story it starts by most accounts
1948 Mahoney City Pennsylvania places I
can't get over there broadcasting now
broadcasters are upset because some
cable TV options are competing in areas
where you can get over-the-air broadcast
television and in 1962 the FCC reversed
just dramatically reversed its policy
and decide to protect broadcasters
because without broadcast television to
give us this news and information our
democracy will suffer we're going to
keep them from siphoning that was the
FCC's word siphoning audience away from
the vast wasteland away from what
they've already identified as the vast
wasteland precisely so at the same time
you know threatening the vast wasteland
with regulation he goes to Washington
and protects them from regulation from
the competitive medium and for years
cable was suppressed and they had arcane
rules some of which are described in the
book about what could if you couldn't
have regular series on cable I mean
they're just picking stuff out of the
air so fast forward in 1979 when you get
deregulation actually ford-carter that
kind of deregulation wave and some court
opinions too
going against the FCC and all of a
sudden now there's this extra capacity
rolling in the markets because these
cable entrepreneurs are laying out
basically more bandwidth okay it's radio
spectrum but it's in a wire it's in a
tube and it's not regulated the same way
so in 1962 when these anti cable rules
come in there is literally 15 minutes a
night for the national news on the three
networks they're not doing news programs
or documentaries or anything like that
by the time you get deregulation and
cable there there comes hundreds of
hours a week thousands of hours a week
why not one of the first things they put
on their congressional hearings ok
Public Interest information c-span on
this historic day the House of
Representatives opens its proceedings
for the first time two televised
coverage c-span comes in 1979 and the
entire structure of c-span and its
possibility to flourish in the
marketplaces due to that deregulation
the way to get a rise on c-span is to
say oh you know but you're you're a
government operation or subsidize or
something it was it is a nonprofit that
runs a private network and funded by the
cable and satellite and broadband
industries that pay to license fees and
a normal market rent a transit
transaction to get the content that was
supposedly only to come on broadcasting
and was actually stymied for 15 years
and now is unleashed into the market
also when cable started going national I
mean and every everybody things were
deregulated that introduced a different
type of politics to write because didn't
every basically every local jurisdiction
would cut a deal with one monopoly cable
operator so even if more more
information is coming in the wire and
run through which it's coming and this
bill causes problems or issue a today
how does how does that fit into all this
stuff so it's like you get freed a
little bit from the broadcaster's
because many of all these channels but
then you're stuck with you know your
cable company which is second only to
used-car salesman is
that's being hated right so you know
this it's never over
yeah okay the next generation has its
own issues its own problems on
challenges so cable is the entrant in
the 1970s and by 1988 more than half US
households subscribe to cable and now
between cable and satellite it's in the
high 90s or something yeah yeah yeah
well it's if you got up to about 90
percent you know and and of course with
broadband now it's declining some
because broadband is taking over in the
next generation
and and in fact cable monopolies are a
very big problem I've written a lot
about this and some of it's in the book
but yeah the cities and municipalities
and the cable franchisees figured out
ways to cut deals and it was very
profitable for companies to cut those
deals and you know by the late 80s
people are talking about the monopoly
problems in cable the recent entrant now
it was a much better monopoly with
c-span and CNN and ESPN oh yeah and in
all kinds of choice and the net then
that of course is evolved in the wake of
this deregulation of this more liberal
environment and for electronic media
that did evolve and I think it's very
very important that we have opened up
you know consistent with your analysis
which is you know there's only villains
in a lot of ways you know and hopefully
when they're the right villains are
attacked in the right villains the
customer wins
well yeah which I could be as positive
as you know yeah nobody's hands are
clean in terms of political parties or
whatnot and in fact I mean one of the
interesting things you see by looking at
the history is that the Fairness
Doctrine which was part of the content
regulation that comes in almost
instantly with radio in the radio act of
1927 has essentially a Fairness Doctrine
within a year or two that's really
harassing left-wing radio stations and
the Fairness Doctrine holds that you
have to give equal time or you have to
represent all points of view well yeah
it's two prong first of all you have to
cover
you have to cover controversial topics
of interest to your community and
secondly do so from balanced
perspectives this may sound like an odd
question but you know in 21st century
America blip eople hear something like
the Fairness Doctrine they're like that
is so self-evidently
a fake way of controlling the news in
the name of being fair I think we're you
know we're cynical where did people back
then understand that as well the idea of
the Fairness Act and what it meant is
that if you were too far to the left or
too far to the right you were going to
be in trouble I mean where they were
they a cynical about kind of government
speak then as we maybe now that's a
great question I mean it doesn't look
like it certainly if you read the
official record and even the criticisms
the official record yeah there was some
criticism but it certainly is taking it
seriously because the law was so
ensconced and in 1987 when the Fairness
Doctrine was abolished by the FCC and
afforded nothing both there there was a
lot of backlash on Capitol Hill the
Democratic majority in the house in
particular one after the FCC and said
that this was just wild deregulation by
the way I was going to mention that the
conservatives were actually in favor of
the Fairness Doctrine and guys like Newt
Gingrich and Jesse Helms liked the
Fairness Doctrine they thought that the
conservatives would not get a fair shake
in a free-market and they wanted the
government enforcement so again there's
no clear hands here right well let's
talk about cellular technology you right
between 1985 and 2014 mobile characters
invested four hundred thirty billion
dollars in network infrastructure and
there's now hundreds of millions of
subscribers for celtech and you compare
that to the slow-moving transition from
analog to digital broadcasting that was
micro managed by the FCC what is what's
the forward-looking policy lesson to be
drawn from that kind of comparison right
so the most famous speech ever given by
a regulator in the United States was the
vast wasteland speech 1961 maybe the
most infamous statement ever made by
certainly an FCC regulator was 1981 by
Marc Fowler the incoming Reagan
appointed chairman of the FCC who said
in a recent magazine interview that
conducted by you I'm a supe no okay
No somebody good who got who got this
comment on the record it's become
infamous you know what to do about
broadcasting and Mark Fowler said well
you know we're treating broadcasting so
different than we you know in other
markets we want to have a lot of
competition we let consumers vote
competition decide and we really should
look at this like it's a toaster with
pictures well you can look at the
citations today that still gets blasted
it is inimical to the public interest
and in the structure of Public Interest
licensing it is an immigrant to the old
mother mae-eye system he's saying let's
regularize this okay they're antitrust
rules or competition policy things going
on let's promote that competition but
let the market figure this out and the
toaster tsunami is I talked about it has
just unleashed not just in content
because we've we've liberalized cable
and the web and everything so much but
when you go to spectrum fewer spectrum
allocations starting with cellular in
the 80s and coming through all the
generations you know 1g 2g 3G 4G now 5g
coming upon us we have gone much more
towards a model where licenses are
auctioned meaning distributed by market
mechanisms to the highest bidders and
the winners get rights to radio spec
they don't get rights to just do one
thing a technology specified in
Washington a business model approved by
regulators only for services that pass
the Public Interest test now we say
here's some radio spectrum stay in your
spot do whatever you want pretty big
ecosystem is yours to create imagine and
play with so you know one of the people
who who comes up again again in your
book and in your footnotes is Ronald
Coase but is that is that you know talk
a little bit of that coast but and how
is the forward-looking policy always
give people you know auction stuff off
and then let people figure out how to
make you know how to make a profit I'm
whatever money they spent on something
yeah in you know in simple terms yes I
mean and when he gets on the scenes
actually studying missile 1950s and he
as an economist is trying to figure out
why the government has to allocate radio
waves and there actually was a curious
exchange in the early 50s with a Leo
Herzl a law students the University of
Chicago actually consider himself a
socialist but had read about market
socialism and how you could have
auctions of government resources and he
thought well let's just do that with
spectrum and he was attacked viciously
by the FCC chief economist at the time
Dallas Smythe who said I was ridiculous
you couldn't do this and Coase actually
read that debate in the University of
Chicago Law Review and thought long and
hard about it investigated how the FCC
operated and came to the conclusion that
the expert smite that his comments were
so incredibly feeble in defense of the
system there must be something to a
market these people have not thought
this through maybe property rights
distributed in a competitive fashion
would allow the market to figure out
what interferes with what and what's the
best way to utilize resources because
coasts instantly saw our job is not to
minimize interference we want to
maximize the value and there's going to
be a lot of interference and in a good
space where there's a lot of good stuff
but you want the low value or the low
cost interference to exist in the
high-cost stuff not to and and you want
to always make these these trail that's
what markets do that's what owners do
they want to maximize the value of the
radio space now coast at first didn't
you know he didn't really have
experiments for this he didn't know if a
market in radio spectrum would work
depend upon it you know transaction cost
is his term but it just depends on on
whether or not private owners can really
make this thing go and kosai to
certainly worth a try
given how inefficient the current system
is and what we know now 50 or more years
later is in coast Goodwyn a nobel prize
some of this thinking that did attract
attention and not just for how we
allocate spectrum but but all kinds of
resources but yeah we've run the
experiments now and that happened with
this liberalisation particularly in what
we
cellular and so those mobile markets
that have evolved yeah we have competing
ecosystems now but just think about it
when when when Edwin Howard Armstrong
comes up in 1934 with FM radio a better
in his mind a better broadcasting system
than he has to go to the Commission and
try to get radio spectrum allocated
didn't work out very well for him
there's a nice long story in the book
that's fairly tragic he ends up as a
great one of the great inventors of the
20th century committing suicide in 1954
in considerable part due to the problems
getting this FM allocation out finally
when when FM is freed up by the
regulator's in the 1960s it almost can
instantly dominates a.m. as in quality
and everything else in the early 2000s
Apple the innovator wants to go on the
radio business it creates an iPhone it
doesn't have to go to Washington and say
mother may i it goes to the carriers who
have individually the rights to use
their spaces now for whatever device
whatever applications whatever content
they whatever business model they think
works not only of course you know the
rest of the story is not only is Apple
successful in buying access to radio
spectrum it's so valuable what they're
producing here is a complement to the
networks that they end up getting paid
and they play the carriers off against
each other and come in and revolutionize
you know ten years ago when the iPhones
introduced revolutionizes you know and
disrupt that space and what we call the
smartphone revolution today under a
mother mae-eye standard that would be
virtually impossible well yeah in one
lifetime deal you know it's the long
delays what business endemic people
understand it regulators understand it
and getting spectrum into the market
that can be turned around and taken out
of something that's not working not
providing value and putting it where it
is that's very difficult let me just
point out the iPhone comes in it
massively interferes with other wireless
devices okay and it's a bandwidth hog
okay but the carrier's know that and
they have to make the trade-off is it
worth it to our customers is it worth it
to our investors that to significantly
even networks to be able to handle all
this data and by the way the current
licenses don't say voice text data they
just give liberal rights to the
operators so it's not all specified the
operators are doing all the optimization
so to speak and they compete with one
another to try to provide better
services so yeah and we just migrated
within this space within these
allocations very small part of the total
spectrum space we've we've actually gone
to a different world
and so what Steve Jobs ended up
achieving with iPhones can be contrasted
directly to what Edwin Howard Armstrong
tried to achieve with FM radio a lot of
the discussion in the current moment
over kind of telecommunications policies
in general internet policy spectrum to a
certain degree has to do with net
neutrality and related concepts net
neutrality is typically defined to mean
that Internet service providers commit
to treating all data is equal and not
prioritizing some streams or clients
content over others and pledging not to
black block access to particular sites
so Comcast if a Comcast as an ISP they
shouldn't be allowed to let NBC shows
which some by the same parent company
get get 2 viewers faster or they should
be able to slow down Netflix or Amazon
streaming etc what's wrong with net
neutrality in general the government
should be neutral with respect to
technology's business models all these
kinds of things but what you're talking
about in terms of what's called net
neutrality is regulation that
particularly restricts certain types of
business models pricing or agreements
between firms and in some cases
consumers now as a general development
of the market you know regulators even
the ones that are Pro in fact especially
the ones that are Pro net neutrality are
very clear the market developed in a
competitive sense with a lot of
neutrality and and and the competitors
have had to do this just to get
customers and that's very well
established in fact the argument for net
neutrality is we don't want this to
change we're trying to free but what
they're freezing is the unregulated
liberalized environment
now it's not completely neutral there's
a lot of non neutrality in what they're
calling neutrality and I'll just give
you one example here we at our home have
cable TV service and cable internet
service and cable telephone service the
cable telephone service competes
directly with AT&T when we have that
phone service in the triple play from
our cable operator we have access
special reserved priority access to the
bandwidth of the cable operator if I go
out and get vonage or do Skype calls we
don't get the same access for that call
as it's being reserved for us there's an
integration between the cable operator
network and the application which is
following voice phone and is there
anything wrong with that
well if you believe in that neutrality
there's a lot wrong with it but the
victory here is clear the incumbent the
mahvel monopoly this is the greatest
victory single victory in some sense for
competition in the regulatory world of
the last 100 years that the you know we
tried to get rid of the Bell monopoly
and now the cable operators for
fixed-line phone service have decimated
it because they do this customized
integrated service which all Babel phone
and is based on treating different
streams of data a different one
absolutely major play that bandwidth is
reserved on a priority basis for the
customers of the cable operator you know
one of the other things that is
fascinating to me because net neutrality
the phrasing is great the way that it's
pitched is it makes it seems of course
who would be against net neutrality but
then you see people getting bent out of
shape if you have a cell phone you know
you might have to rise on or t-mobile or
whatever will say hey you can listen you
know and you you buy four gigabytes of
data a month and if you listen to music
or watch TV on your phone you go through
that pretty quickly but we won't count
against your data cap if you watch
Netflix streaming or you have Amazon or
you listen to Rhapsody or Spotify right
that's a violation of that neutrality
right is that the worst case scenario
because Arthur Arthur
lot of sites that are being blocked or
is net fect Netflix being systematically
slowed down by certain cable operators
in order to shake you know so they can
shake them down for more money I just
point out that there have been three
rounds of FCC rules on instituting forms
of net neutrality the second the second
round which came out very late in 2010
had a very interesting outcome and that
was that the first complaint filed under
those rules in 2011 was lodged against a
small relatively small the number five
u.s. mobile operator united states metro
pcs it's now been acquired by t-mobile
okay metro pcs was doing the cheapest
phone service around it was like $40 a
month all-you-can-eat but they had some
older technology and if there was
unlimited streaming of particularly
YouTube which is very popular I don't
have to tell you that that didn't work
very well for their network so what they
did is they actually went to the owner
of YouTube which is Google and said can
you help us on this we really like to
give our customers access but in our
network being what it is
Google being what it is I said yeah I
would you know we put some engineers on
it here's a little here's a little way
to help ease the pain for your network
and now MetroPCS comes back in the
market and gives unlimited streaming
video streaming it's part of its
all-you-can-eat package but it's to
YouTube these other things don't work as
well now MetroPCS had no interest in
youtube they had they did not own Google
Google did not own them they're just
trying to attract customers there is a
policy analysis of this called antitrust
law and the first thing you've noted and
so that's prevailing you know since 1890
at least we've had antitrust law to
govern anti-competitive behavior
there's no anti-competitive behavior
MetroPCS has no market power they're
just trying to get customers they're not
trying to flip people over to the
YouTube site because they're trying to
exclude Netflix they got a network that
we happy to do for Netflix what they
they did for Google if Netflix are given
the same cooperation on
on the the traffic problem so now that
is blatantly you've got the government
regulators saying we're that we're going
to enforce neutrality we're not going to
recognize the fact that neutrality came
out of the market that's the neutrality
we like we're not going to recognize the
fact that there's some non neutrality
that's really Pro consumer and we're
going to have blanket rules against this
and I think really the travesty is
already a regulatory scheme for that
it's all antitrust law you can have the
Department of Justice or a private suit
file under the antitrust laws if there
really is discrimination there is an
anti consumer discrimination on that and
so this zero-rating stuff shows you how
quickly just instantly you can get an
anti consumer behavior because a rule
sounds good
in a general behavioral outcome of a
competitive market which is broad
neutrality is turned into a law that
doesn't understand the nuance Trump
Donald Trump President Trump has named
Ajit PI head of the FCC was a
commissioner who was appointed under a
Republican seat highes famously he told
us in an interview a couple years ago
that net neutrality is a bad idea to a
problem that doesn't exist
and the it seems like the FCC is either
going to rescind or massively
deprioritized net neutrality rules is
that good or I assume you would say that
is good but and are you hopeful for Paes
FCC do you think he'll push in a market
direction that will be beneficial to
entrepreneurs to innovation and
ultimately to customers I am hopeful
that pi is the best choice that
president Trump could have made and the
possible set and let me just say 100
years from now there won't be an FCC
okay I just you just can't see that the
kinds of regulatory structure that's
there now it's going to fit a little
it'll be part of the Department of
Agriculture I don't think we need that
either well yeah yeah that's my
predictor the question is how much
sooner
how much sooner can we get to you know
there still be disputes about spectrum
and so forth there might be a special
spectrum Court like we have maybe
specialized bankrupt
courts or patent courts but there'll be
a different structure now along the way
of course we're still the short-run
we're still where we are and a guy like
Pi is very knowledgeable and I think has
learned a lot of the lessons of
regulation deregulation and what
confronts us now I think it's it's I
mean certainly out of this
administration you could have done a lot
worse so so PI's on the right track
you've actually said that they're going
to have some Pro economic reforms and
get more economic decision-making in
that's the most recent release and
that's on the right track too because if
there's more cost-benefit scrutiny and
it's done right it's taken seriously if
I might do that then that that'll be
positive so let's talk about reforms you
write that spectrum pop the spectrum
policy answer here is auction overlay
rights explain in layman terms what
auction overlay rights are okay so in
1952 plus or minus a year or two we had
a vast radio spectrum allocation for
broadcast television okay that was the
killer app of 1952 okay most of that
spectrum is still sitting right where it
was despite the fact that essentially
broadcast television spectrum as a
useful application has gone away it's
all cable and satellite over the top now
broadband but it's the same people who
are the same corporate entities that got
those rights and 52 basically still have
otherwise yeah a lot of trading run and
then you know what it's still four
generations gone but that there those
licenses themselves are restricted to
one transmitter doing over-the-air
blasting through six megahertz of space
on an advertising only model can't you
know you can't do two subscription and
you can't really do two-way
communications you have to do this
specified you know mother mae-eye in
Washington so we've been peeling it was
82 channels the pv to begin with it's
now down to 49 there's been a procedure
at the FCC it's going to reallocate
about another 10 of those channels to
the mobile operators and an auction
that's just ending right now and so
we're making progress
peeling TV band off but it's slow and it
takes years in fact the current auction
was put forward in the early 2000s and
was officially adopted as a policy in
2009-2010 in the National Broadband Plan
2017 we're ending an auction to assign
rights and then it's going to be
potentially another three years or so to
actually get the spectrum freed up for
the new stuff so I think it takes it
takes a long time what what you could do
as an alternative is you could look at
the TV ban just to use an example and
you could say look in in in all these
markets we're just going to give out new
rights new licenses call it an overlay
the new overlay would be a right that we
sold at auction and the new owner high
bidder would have the right to use all
the TV channels that aren't being used
which is most of them the great majority
of them and have a secondary right to
use the occupied TV channels where there
is TV broadcasting and what that does is
it allows the new owner to negotiate
with the TV station here take some money
go away just go on cable and satellite
we'll see you later go share a channel
with somebody else and you know another
assignment or gold brought do whatever
you want the great thing about this is
there's very little regulatory overhead
you can do it fast the FCC has actually
done these overlays before they have
it's off-the-shelf regulatory technology
and and the nice thing is you don't have
to tell the incumbents to move which is
always a big political problem that's
the big holdup you don't tell you have
all the rights you used to have okay if
you're going to have one extra right and
that is to make a deal with the overlay
owner and then you put a responsible
party in to the market that can
negotiate and use all the stuff that's
not being used and pay people to go away
and do something more efficient and
bring Wall Street bring Silicon Valley
that you got the technology you got the
financial capital let's do something
that's really doing the most good
society with a spectrum do it in a
competitive way you're going to migrate
to a better world with great innovation
much more rapidly and there are many
ways to do that in many places to do it
including where there are a lot of
government uses and lots of spectrum you
know probably 75 80 percent is still
walled off or very inefficient uses you
can come in there and even where the
government is there now you can have
private companies come in and make deals
with government agencies
you know maybe OMB is a referee or other
various you know and sundry institution
what what would you said the political
odds of a reform along those lines
moving forward well as I said we have
done this in some cases with the only
reason we got to G which was called pcs
in him in 1990s is there were 4500
microwave users in that ban and the
threat really coming from senators in
you know here in Washington Ernest
Hollings took up with you people will
die if you use a spectrum for anything
other than these like public utility
uses that serve very few people well
nobody died okay what we figured out the
Commission the regulators to their
credit figured out they could give out
new licenses and and have the new
licensees pay the existing licensees to
go do something else and use other
spectrum and there was a cooperative
system there in 2006 we actually had a
big auction for what's called AWS
advanced wireless services and there
were government users that were there
and companies like t-mobile had to
figure out ways to move them out rapidly
to get 3G technologies into the market
and that worked pretty well now they're
better ways to do it we're learning
about that but this this is something
that a democratic commissioner
Jessica rosenworcel is actually
suggested that there's that the BBC even
calls and I think bounty rights to the
sell off the rights to bargain with
government agencies this is exactly how
you want to think about you want to
think about these market incentives
really liberalizing the process of
spectrum allocation because the trick
here is that while we have liberalized
the licenses in a lot of cases we still
have the spectrum allocation regime of
1927 we still go case-by-case and when
there's a liberalisation it's
one here it's one there we want to just
go much faster and much broader and
that's the way we get all this pretty
amazing new stuff into the market final
question
how did you get interested in spectrum
as a subject of study I actually is in a
dissertation at UCL a few semesters back
did take a look at cable TV franchising
that was fascinating because here was a
new sort of a public utility but it
wasn't and it was regulated to public
utility but it wasn't
lots of rent-seeking politics you know
just fun stuff and I started looking at
that and then I became a professor at
the University of California Davis and I
somehow I got invited to write a chapter
for a book in England on American
Broadcasting on the US broadcasting
market and and I wrote the chapter and
it was never published
somehow that's all through the cracks
but along the way I discovered that the
origins of the US regulatory system were
widely misunderstood by the Supreme
Court by legal scholars and that there
was this very rational system that was
in place in fact I wrote published an
article in 1990 in the journal on
economics called the rationality of US
regulation of the broadcast spectrum and
you know I slightly criticized Ronald
Coase for not seeing how much of a
market had developed how much how much
people were relying on property rules
early on in the radio market and how
that was developing I just
parenthetically know coast was predicted
by many people to never get a Nobel
Prize as soon as I criticized him just a
little bit 1991 he got the price up so I
don't penalize people for free anymore
you know but but anyway it was
fascinating to me that the development
of property rights was very well
understood there was no error as cos
added about they didn't understand this
oh no they understood completely and
there's a lot of rent-seeking going on
between the incumbent radio stations and
the politicians that wanted more
influence over content and the favors
that they were awarding and it was a
very usually what we call shared capture
in political science or economics public
choice they got together and actually
had a very successful coalition that
took over in the 1927 radio act on
public interest standard but soon free
speech and unorthodox views we're
suffering in the air and of course there
was this restriction and barriers going
up so the people I get when Howard
Armstrong and the FM technologies
couldn't get in and compete with
incumbents so that's been with us it's
still with us we've we've done away with
enough of it so that we've led in a huge
part of the innovative world and that's
been tremendously successful we have to
build on that and really expand to the
spectrum allocation structure those
liberalization measures that's the
battle ahead all right
well and you write about it at length
and with great interest in your new book
we have been talking with Thomas Winslow
Haslet about his new book the political
spectrum the tumultuous liberation of
wireless technology from Herbert Hoover
to the smartphone Tom thanks so much
thank you for reason I'm Nick Gillespie